beautiful thank you [__] hey you said
frig I'll wait a minute like to propose
a toast to my family someday soon you're
gonna have families of your own and if
you're lucky you'll remember the little
moments like this
that were good
Oh
hey buddies this is good time so my name
is Li science no it's not my name's
Steven one of the best kind of little
kid laughter and when you were little
like when I was little and I cuz I had
cousins who were probably around the age
I am now I have to get the laugh out
okay I always thought they were the
coolest don't always do stuff like that
to them mm-hmm and it's always even if
it's a like I don't think kids know what
fake laughs are so yeah I only get
anything it's like oh the cool guy thing
I think I'm funny yeah do it when I
little Steven is in his very immature
sense of humor face so he thinks I'm a
genius what do you do it's a lot of like
bathroom humor that he finds hilarious I
still I don't think I've ever loved that
stage I don't know I still find that
funny
yeah so I want to thank everybody for
praying for a little Steven and praying
for William and Raoul everybody seems to
be doing better so just keep that up
that's it that's all I got that's great
news yeah it's it's it's good so that's
that's it it's always it's uh health is
very important and it's great that it's
great that you're going down and it's
great that they're doing better yeah hi
everything how are you doing I'm doing
pretty good I'm so excited to have
Christina on the podcast it's such a
good episode like I did her podcast
that's deep bro and I listened to you I
remember when I first met you you were
already listening that Tama Kristina's
podcast your mom's house oh yeah it's
still one of my favorite like top two I
got the only two a podcast that I
listened to that I'm not involved in or
there's a norisse yeah that's really all
I have time for now yep it's amazing but
it's such a good podcast and with such
cool people and then she's about to be a
mom so that's pretty that's pretty great
for good times yeah I don't think
there's anything more important except
yeah the more I think about it there's
nothing more important like last night I
did a podcast with Jeremiah Watkins from
the comedy series and it was interesting
he was such a great podcast I can't wait
to share that one with you guys like I
just what I'm kind of thinking all right
see if this makes sense okay
all right ideally I would like to get
two guests in a row like I loved when I
had the crab feast guys right it was
like Sickler and then larsen and then I
think then we did Christine little I
think what would be a really cool kind
of format would be if I had access to
two I don't want to use the word famous
or two people that are gonna bring
listeners to the show mm-hmm in a row
like crap these guys I don't know what
those numbers were I'm sure I'm gonna
keep on going up and then I would like
to do two if if we kid like I think this
would be a good strategy to grow the
podcast you're the business guy I'm not
but if we did two guests in a row
that'll bring listeners mmm and then the
third guest somebody really cool and
interesting that I want to share with
our listeners to more or less help them
like I think Christine little so funny
so I'm glad we got to share them and
then like Jeremiah he's such a young guy
that a lot of people don't know who he
is yet but he's hilarious so it's like
last week we had harloff he's bringing
listeners that schmoes know Empire he's
built right yeah and then Christina will
bring listeners and then boom next week
Jeremiah and then I think like Craig
Gass wants to do it Eric Griffin said he
would do it like if I could sort of
follow that pattern I think that might
be good make that it makes sense it's we
can keep it up right right if you can
keep it up and only tough and it is nice
when you can have people who have their
own base like their own listenership
that will come and listen but it's also
like there's no way I would have found
out about you without podcast yeah
that's what makes it so cool so even
even if you don't know them yet that's
that some of the best podcast is when
you have no expectations you're just
listening to it which is why it's it
always confuse like it's it confuses me
that a lot of listeners won't listen to
podcast based on the guest like it's
always interesting looking the numbers
yeah it's weird and then you're like oh
this one was bigger sorry maybe it's
their listeners but then some people
just look because I get it people are
busy too yes I I like to think like just
make it cool right just have an
interesting conversation yeah that's it
that's all I want to do
with no agenda really but it's
interesting that some people just book
their podcast like it was a bad late
night show anybody with Fame and then
they have a very surface level stinky
like I don't want that I want to get
interesting and cool and really get to
know somebody and I think that works
best when I don't have an agenda right
but I think because I tried it last
night with Jeremiah and I think it's
something I want to do in the future
okay my manager was like you know it
would be interesting baby if you asked
people just one question and for every
guest and just see what he wasn't she
was like if that if you were to do that
what question do you think so I we
somehow or I saw I don't know how I
asked him out of because we had a really
cool talk okay then out of everybody in
his life if he had to pick one person
who had the biggest impact on his life
positive or negative is it a family
members and a mentor is it a hero is it
as a great question and I think because
like I I thought about it for me and I'm
like you know what out of everybody I
would have to say my younger brother
really would and like that's it's you
it's reflected in my stand-up to you
know like there's a lot of material
about him because we just you know we
spent so much time together during this
formative years and then he's just such
a positive role model now like you know
he said dad he's a businessman he's a
husband all the things I would I would
love to be at some point that's a hard
question to answer
yeah who would it be for you I have no
idea I was trying to think about it and
then also like well now that I'm
thinking about I don't wanna hurt
anybody anybody's feel know that yes
you'd have to answer it very tactfully
but uh okay think about that while I
mentioned we'll do it in the in the
who's so you think it's your brother
yeah comedic Lee or personally no right
no no I mean personally well I mean
personal like if one person that's had
the biggest impact I would have to here
think about it and we had some sponsors
yeah I do and I don't think about the
unofficial sponsor Don Carlos taco shop
ask for Ryan he's located on Pearl
Street in La Jolla California eat a
burrito calm is his website and so
delicious I'm gonna be down there I
think in two weeks on the 29th and then
I'd like to do a podcast with Ryan and
then I recorded a podcast with Mike PI
the guy that owns freak we're calm
but what I'm thinking about is now that
uh we've been building up his brand a
little bit here on good times maybe have
him come in and do a live one that'd be
great yeah and then you get to meet him
- because he's so cool okay sounds nice
yeah he's super nice but he's like a
strong bodybuilder guy they could snap
our necks if you wanted to if he wasn't
it's he could be our bodyguards yes yeah
that's so funny yeah yeah and his
website super cool and I've noticed like
on Instagram I'm like I'm getting like
more like Fitness people following me
and stuff and I think it's because of
we're mentioning freak we're on the
podcast I think because you're looking a
little buff these days yeah I mean here
you say that not giggle though I am
doing more cardio yeah and I'm doing the
I'm doing the diet Mike recommended but
it's tough this no carbs thing sucks and
you know what man
I started thinking about this number one
freak where fr ekw a re calm super cool
it's not just but it's more of a
lifestyle company it's like hey man just
be you and help the world in the process
don't be a fraidy-cat right that's kind
of like the vibe I'm getting from a like
you know where the shirt dude be a freak
go do your thing you do you yeah the
rest will take care of itself it's
interesting it's great with it yeah it
is really really cool and I'm it I think
it's just cool whenever companies get
involved in sponsoring it makes me feel
a lot more like a real like were like
when I did re show last week I felt like
I was in show business and then like now
my buddy Mac down in Florida he's got
this whole proposal for doing a coloring
book but it's gonna cost a lot of money
like it's gonna be like seven thousand
bucks just in artwork so like my my my
fear is that even if we go to the effort
of putting together a whole GoFundMe
campaign or whatever crowd-sourced
funding stuff Kickstarter yeah whatever
it is that we're not going to raise
enough money I don't want him and his
buddies to do any more work on this
project until they start getting paid I
have a problem with that so he sent over
a proposal or as I K these are all the
tip like it could be from because he
wants
to the Chinese food bit as a coloring
book right and it was like maybe if you
give five bucks you get crayons all the
way up to like a thousand bucks and you
get drawn in the comic you get drawn in
the book and we go out for Chinese food
together that would be super cool and
you could bring the book to color with
yes like stuff like that would be so fun
but I don't know like I might need to do
do crowdfunding for a special or I don't
want to burn people out right and I got
to be honest not like all these people
are like yeah I'll buy a coloring book
I'm like well you didn't really buy a CD
so how how am I gonna think that you're
gonna buy a coloring book to like I'm
gonna be honest I didn't sell that many
CDs and it's like we have the Amazon
link on awesome Steve calm nobody's used
it yet you know so go to awesome where
is it on awesome Steve calm it's right
on that soon as you get through the
video okay so yeah go cuz people people
use them for all the podcast and I'll
use it so if you're listening to this
please go to awesome Steve calm and use
the Amazon like it really because
christmas is coming up
Monica's coming up yeah and especially
if you could use business expenses so
it's not even your money
that's rest looking airline miles when
you're not spending the money yeah what
I'm saying is I just need to keep this
going and I need support and I don't
want anybody I don't okay I'm if
anybody's gonna work for free it's gonna
be me and I get that because I think I'm
building a connection with all you guys
that listen and it's gonna eventually
help my comedy career as soon as my
agent starts getting me booked more like
whenever I get out on the road it's
wonderful to have friends right so if
this podcast is just my way of making
friends cool but I don't want Lee I
don't want you working for free
I don't want Bryce and the website
working for free and I don't want Mack
and his crew doing any more
illustrations like I'm gonna have them
do a new cover for my CD okay but I'm
gonna pay them for it right and then I'm
gonna get a thousand CDs printed up and
then people who buy them on awesome
Steve calm with a different cover and
it'll be cool
same old CD but a different and then
that way I can sell them on the road a
club decision yeah yeah and then that's
it but it's like I I don't want to have
to like raise ten thousand dollars for a
stupid book that what if we only wind up
raising three thousand well the cool
thing about Kickstarter's if you don't
reach your goal that no one's money gets
taken okay I don't know so yeah
if you read your goal then it goes but
if it doesn't then it just nothing oh
that's cool
yes you could at least test the waters
alright I this is a phone called a Mac
but it's like I'm so busy I have like a
little Kimmy event this weekend I gotta
get down to the hospital I gotta go meet
people it's like I don't I need to
listen to more episodes of good times
just to relax and chill
cuz it's I don't have any time right
like cuz now I'm getting back into my
script last night I was driving this is
how God works and how awesome life is I
was driving over the hill to go to the
comedy store to record another podcast
and I'm like what am i doing like I need
a day off right yeah so that I'm driving
over the hill and soon as I get down to
Sunset and Laurel I see my buddy that's
homeless that hangs out at the Comedy
Store and he has one of those signs and
I'm like don't even look over there and
he walks over the cars like hey Steve
how's it going buddy and I was like I
want to be in a bad mood you're taking
away my bad mood so then I talked to him
and I gave him money and he was I was
like she need a ride to the Comedy Store
he's like yeah I got a couple more hours
of work but that I'll be down there
after I'm like oh my god you proved your
point yeah that sometimes when you're in
a stinky mood the only thing you have to
do is make time for somebody else and
then your stinky mood goes away that's
so interesting make time for somebody
else yeah I've noticed it but it's a
delicate balance because you also need
to recharge yourself yeah and sometimes
like I was like I gotta recharge myself
and then I saw my buddy and that made me
happier than recharging right and then
also like do you ever feel guilty about
recharging cuz it's not like you're
going into an office for eight hours a
day so now you know you're not
constantly you're not at work all the
time but you're constantly making calls
or writing yeah I think it's a little
more difficult like they all have their
pros and cons right right oh yeah
absolutely
um but it never seems like we ever clock
out which is not a good thing no right
cuz it's like midnight on a Monday and
I'm finishing up a podcast and then
people you know it's not good but it is
what it is it's fun it's fun and it's
the I don't know what I would do without
comedy cuz I love you guys for listening
and all the emails you guys
and then all the positive reviews on
iTunes and stitcher thank you guys so
much the question that you asked means
really I will come back to it after this
why don't we add yeah it's doing in the
outro will have christina pazsitzky i
she's one of my favorite people ever i'm
so happy to finally get her on this
podcast where are you gonna be the you
of you of dates coming up don't you
October 29th I'm in San Diego
Montana stuff got canceled Minnesota
Minnesota at the end of November at the
house of comedy New York for the Comedy
Festival with Gabriel we're playing The
Beacon Theater it's gonna be sick dude
on the 12th I think and then bring me to
your Christmas party go to awesome Steve
come to book me that would be awesome
yes somebody out there I want to do your
Chris York or for Christmas party that
would be the best and I'll bring candy
canes you guys can find Christina on
Twitter at Christina P I hope you guys
enjoy this episode as much as I did
check-check I think it's working meow
meow meow yep
so you want to do an episode on humility
well I was thinking just because of this
generation it's it's not cool to be
mm-hmm
to be humble or to be self-aware
everybody wants to be a rapper Kanye
West yeah it's that yuck society I call
so gross yes so yuck it's so sad it's
like so filled with pride and misery
like those people miserable but
miserable and completely filled with
fear well if you want to see what true
suffering is go to Instagram and look at
like a Kardashians also if you want to
see what self-loathing is did I ever
tell you what my theory on all that was
that's terrible and I wanted to say this
on stage but I can't work up a
connection with an audience I have an
idea for a show that I really want to do
a stand-up show okay were you coming
with material that just doesn't fit your
voice or your point of view because I
have some really mean I have some really
mean stuff I want to say on stage but I
can't make it work in my set and I'm
sure like somebody like the Louis CK's
got the sweetest stuff that or Bill burr
and I think I can't how can I talk about
ice cream when I'm in the middle of
saying why everything's wrong but my
theory is this yeah Robert and I
shouldn't say this and I kind of I could
see this why I couldn't do it on stage a
sense of here's the premise I don't know
I really hope this isn't true but I
think maybe Robert Kardashian's in
health and it's his children's lives
playing out in front of him that is his
hell oh wow that's interesting like he's
got a front row seat where Satan's like
sit down your daughter's gonna be famous
which one is it Kimmy well which well
what's she famous football she makes a
video Oh what kind of video a music
video kinda there's some kind of well
what does she do oh sweet baby Jesus and
then he has he's like I have to make
sure nobody's daughter winds up like
this
no every daughter because of your
daughter winds up like this where
aspires to be yeah but I can't make it
work cause it's a little it's not it's
not your lane I want to remind people I
have to find the light myself and then
share that with the world yeah because
if I just wanted to walk out and say
John poop on things I could hear that
all day long that's what I like to do
it's cathartic sometimes though right
yeah and especially when a woman does it
I feel like it's not like it's even more
subversive when a woman has an opinion
which is why I like to have more I think
yes it's so true it's a domme like why
is it such a big deal if a woman just
has an opinion it's really blows their
minds it's so as for as far as people
think when women's issues have
progressed they I think they've actually
gotten worse it's regressive it's
regressed right it's anything even if
you look at the comedy landscape if you
saw what sells right now oh it's the eye
with no idea every chip I shouldn't say
this but it's like they took the ISIS
persona from 88 and just feminized it
don't the guy gobble come I got all that
and I'm like exactly I'm like this is so
sad it's happening and it's sad and
everybody's kissing their asses I agree
that's why I'm so happy you're on the
comedy game loved your story the other
thing put this part going up whatever
you want I don't know it was record for
three minutes in we haven't said
anything bad oh no I'm just gonna say I
felt weird that felt that storytelling
show felt weird and my husband was like
you're supposed to wear as a story to
story my egos used to that's why you
know what I did three minutes a stand-up
upfront okay now I'm gonna sit down and
tell a story you know I was still
capable and then I'm like okay brace
yourself because they're not it's gonna
be a different thing it's a different
and they're a little judgy whatever so
um but I was gonna say that the the
landscape is so regressive because if
you look at somebody like a Roseanne
Barr yeah who was fat on unfuckable
yeah loud-mouthed and hysterical in
middle class or middle class yet would
never exist it's very hard to sell that
today and I think it's Beveridge human
the average human and it's the lad mag
culture it's that all women should want
to [__] we should be [__] and
agreeable and like you said like I just
love sucking [__] it's this patriarchal
it's yes and it's it's so um scary
it's actually scary yeah because there's
no respect for women either of course
not it's like even like
look I wasn't around fifty years ago but
I listen to the music you know and if
that's any indication there were like
old school gender roles but it seems
like even with that there was a respect
attached to it no it's dick [__] yeah
it's my nuts and the girls are dancing
to it in the clubs like yes embracing
edge
yeah like somewhere along the line I
don't know how this was embraced as
feminism yeah but it's like you're my
pleasure bot right that's all it is
right and definitely don't have an
opinion definitely I don't know how like
I like to think of myself as a feminist
meaning if my daughter grew up and she
was like hey Dad I want to be a surgeon
I'd be like yes I want to jump out of
planes yes
or if she was like you know what I want
to go teach preschool I'd be like it
whatever you want to do do something do
something yeah but now it just seems
like it seems like being hot is the
priority in the culture you got to be
hot but what's that agreeable yeah it's
it's terrifying because I grew up in the
90s and 80s were we had these subversive
role models I had Janeane Garofalo how
lucky was I yeah I had shirley manson
from garbage like yeah how lucky what
happened to that there was a really cool
yet that that sort of movement sort of
just disappeared the anti the the answer
to the the fembot so to speak yeah
sexualize how do we step back I think
what happened is women's lib got
confused with sexual liberation right so
the whole idea of like calling us [__]
if we call ourselves [__] and own
sexuality somehow that makes it more
feminine than feminized feminists but I
still don't attend the logic because
we're just doing what you guys want us
to do now and now you don't have to
treat us like a human like humans it's
so confusing for a single guy my guess
is the source of like all the negative
stuff in my life
it's a microwave a second the second I
feel like I start to care is the second
they're like there's such a lack of love
in society right the second you turn
into a person you mean yeah I'd like to
have a person yeah like soon as I start
returning your phone calls
there there I forget it and how does
dating cuz like when I started dating my
husband Tom it was literally around
Friendster that's hysterical I never
knew grinder or grinds for gay dudes I
mean what's that one tinder
yeah I don't do any of that stuff
because I'm like if I meet a chick on
one of those websites I'm like yeah it's
like I already know too much like if I
ever make money I'm not gonna buy a nice
car I don't want a girl to be like
that's what it's sad but it's like yeah
social medias Rowan dating - oh my god
she seems like a nice girl and then I'm
like oh pull side at the Venetian give
him the finger to the cat Cara I'm like
goodbye goodbye to many Vegas pictures
too many nightclub pictures trash trash
too many selfies too much duct thing
selfies is the saddest thing it's so sad
too many hashtags the more of our
hashtags something well you know what
the saddest god yeah well chicks are
like set life went in for a killer
audition I'm like do you think Robert
DeNiro is like take a picture in front
of me craft services I want to know what
everybody there now I wanted everybody
know I'm here I know I'm a star
oh it's so sad yes generation it's like
second third generation no hugs no love
no no nothing possible war I think it's
it might be the opposite I think it's us
our generation feeling deprived because
we were latchkey kids and our parents
yeah and now we give too much approval
how much interesting too much adoration
it's validate everything I tweet
star it favorite like me YouTube make
comments tell me how great I am
what am i great this is what I think
[__] the way I we've replaced attention
we've replaced love with attention yes
that's all it is people just want
attention they don't want love because
love comes with responsibility
interesting and heartache can owner
ability yeah nobody wants to be
vulnerable people are too fearful so if
it she's like give me the attention yeah
and that's it well on Plus vulnerability
leads to punishment at least in social
media Oh
in life in life like when you get
vulnerable
I realized a mistake I'd made throughout
a lot of my life was I was like I wanted
to love somebody without but still
trying to protect myself I'm like oh you
can't do that
that's the price you pay for admission
you love you have to be vulnerable yeah
like I have no idea like you're
preparing it for a little guy to show up
oh my god that scares me like I mean I'm
not even dating a girl that but I'm like
first day of school man I don't know I'm
gonna be crying the worst you know what
though it took me many years to get
vulnerable with my husband it took many
years of therapy yeah I'll be able to
get there cuz it's comics we're so
sensitive so sensitive but at the same
time we would deflect that sensitivity
yeah you don't want anybody know it yeah
like that's why I just owned everything
now I'm just like hey man I don't really
know what I'm doing but I'm trying my
best
yeah that's all you can hope for you
know what I was thinking too the
vulnerability thing in social media
culture is that people are ashamed so
much now there's the outrage mob that'll
go on you and you it's really dangerous
and it's really scary for comedy like
after I my re show we taped a few days
ago I looked on my Twitter feed and it
was a lot of complimentary and then one
guy like I found here's your story to be
racially insensitive and defensive and
then he like tagged Comedy Central on
here to penalize me right god right and
it's like wait a minute
what part of my story was incensed at
the part where I was bullied and beaten
yes I was in my story or the fact that I
had the the the wherewithal to joke
about it 20 years later and was it about
me and a black girl yeah but [__] so
what people it's so crazy how people
tense up the second race gets mentioned
those words yes it's and it's like hey
man you're robbing that person of their
humanity if you don't see them as a
person that's right if you just see them
as like hey we have to treat that person
that's different for me has to be
perfect
it's like number one you
never you it's such a sheltered point of
view yeah it's like come on man we're
all human beings nobody's perfect and
that's there's a certain perfection to
that does that make sense soon as you
get to know somebody in spite of their
flaws and perfections then you're like
oh I can never get mad at you of course
but I understand why you're an ass
culture of penalizing people on speaking
there their minds now on Twitter people
lose jobs now it's awful because the
outraged mob is look at poor rent is
easy who off looking love sweetest guy
in the world and he's fantastic and
because once to generous person I've
ever met
course and one thing and he gets you
know money pulled he's got kids to take
care of it's such a judgmental society
or and for nothing really for nothing
and not really judging the relevant
parts no that's thrown out things like
everybody's an [__] and they love
pointing out how much of an [__]
everybody else is but over over the
wrong bits Oh over the right like why
don't we you should be on Bill Cosby
like that guy's house should be burned
to the ground right now what about woody
allen like how does that guy get a pass
he rapes his own kids and we're gonna
give him a Lifetime Achievement Award
[__] Roman Polanski oh my god what a
creep
yeah but Holly show business gives him a
high-five and lets him back you know oh
my god what's wrong with the world I
don't know Steve we need to run things
wait please you know what I wrote we do
need normal people kick out all the
politicians and just like grandmother's
I don't think anybody should be allowed
to hold office unless you're at least 65
and a mom that's it like that everything
will get solved um are 65 I think I
think there's something in the age I
think you're right yeah you have to go
through life feel it understand what's
going on and be like unconditional love
yeah all right so fired up today it's
the heat I think we're gonna break he
and fired out the best what we started
to talk about your podcast that's deeper
oh yeah yes and that's what got into it
and then you we talked about your story
all right this is what I remember when I
was on your podcast you started to tell
me a story about seeing chunk from the
Goonies and inadvertently I wore my
Goonies t-shirt wouldn't even know I
don't even know consciously weird is
it's the best because okay this podcast
let's try to I like when things get deep
but I also like just celebrating simple
fun stuff and you grew up and you were
saying this the other day oh my god save
it for the podcast yeah you grew up in a
time frame where it was the California
that I fell in love with as a kid in
suburban Philadelphia like I remember I
ordered my first skateboard from Val
surf right in the valley it was a pink
tourney Tony Hawk skateboard and I was
like California is the coolest place in
the world yeah what was it like growing
up in calc was it like Fast Times at
Ridgemont High what was the line can I
tell you it kind of was I mean even
though that movie's older than me mm-hmm
they were the teenagers and I was the
kid and that mall that it was yelled and
I hung out at that oh no way you hung
out at the mall where Mark Ratner was a
really a movie theater there I remember
it's exactly set up that way there's hot
dog on a stick but then it all changed
later yeah that's why I walk to that
mall where that mall used to it yeah now
it's different really different but I
got to grow up in that mall and I got to
kind of live that valley girl and the
time valley girl was really pop it's the
moon SAP I was like start selling those
shirts again and kill it just gag me
with a spoon and and it was the culture
of Venice Beach was really different it
was back when it was remember that movie
Fletch yes and there's that guy and he's
on a he's on roller skates and he's
playing an electric guitar and it's got
swirls on it that was real you know yeah
that guy the second time like I've been
referenced in the past week Arizona last
week this guy told me he went to college
in Arizona and that guy was on campus
then before he moved to Venice well
we'll see cuz that guy I grew up
watching like crazy people like that guy
Venice used to be just girls in dolphin
shorts and weight lifters at Muscle
Beach people juggling chainsaws you know
fleeting act and and it was certainly
yeah it was like a cool parade of lunacy
and break dancers the break dancers were
awesome and the skateboarders like
skaters were everywhere oh yeah I was in
anytime you know what I just realized
from that act though people had to earn
their attention then it was like you
want to passion breakdance bro do the
windmill spin on your head
that's right fly out of this concrete
bowl on your skateboard and not snap
your neck
Juden how hard was break dancing like
Empire it was the ticket to cool it was
like an elementary and we had nobody to
breakdance for so we'd breakdance for my
grandmother did you just clap her hands
no very good and my big brother would
have a stop-motion light setup
own it jam own it my little brother
would come out with like a karate kid'
head bent and do the robot for my
grandmother what was your move ah I used
to try to do the back spin and then
that's the worm or centipede and you
could do it yeah I could do that and I
would do that like I remember the first
middle school dance I did that and I was
like who's cool this guy did you like
you know how in all the 80s dance movies
there was like clear circle so that
happened yes it happened for you yeah I
was a complete [__] though everybody I
don't Chris Farley was the first person
I've ever heard use this expression
where he imitated the nuns talking to
his mom and Farley said mrs. Farley the
children aren't laughing with
Christopher laughing at Christopher and
I think I kind of had that as a kid like
I needed the attention I would I thought
I wanted to be chunk from Goonies he was
rad yeah like I was a fat kid that would
wear Hawaiian shirts and like parachute
pants I was trying so hard to be cool
well chunk okay so chunk he lived in the
San Fernando Valley so I grew up in the
San Fernando Valley at one time so many
stars lived there it was a place where
it was glamorous it wasn't it wasn't
what it is now I think now it's a bit
worn down maybe in places but yeah um
celebrities like I would go to a seafood
restaurant and I saw a Gallagher when i
knowwe like 9 yeah and i lost my mind
and you would go to Coco's I went to
Coco's my mom and we saw a chunk and all
these other kids were there and they
were like dude and he did it he went
around the corner and he did the truffle
shuffle and like
Koko's lit up that's amazing and like
Fred Savage was that my grad night no
way Kevin Arnold was at your drag night
Wow how was that even positive different
school but like we saw him in line like
he was in the line next was like oh you
know who's my favorite fighting dude
there's used to be this place called
Skateland you roller-skated and like I
can't believe I've been doing this
podcast for a year and a half and
nobody's mentioned rollerskating not
even for Ernst one historian yeah he
didn't even do the Tony's story well
yeah there is this dope place called
skate land and that's where you had your
first kiss your first cigarette
you should write a movie about skate
lamp no right
could you met doctor should you like be
like the John Hughes from Utrecht that
would be an amazing I already love him I
write down right yeah write that down
skate with is the way you just described
that first cigarette first kiss first
ever yeah it was the it was the coolest
and you felt so cool because there was a
DJ you know and you like roll out came
now dude can you play what's that Lisa
Lisa called JJ trying to get the DJ's
attention yes one as a 12 year old can
you play the karai I love the Three
Stooges and people would I'd be like
play the Curley shuffle and see what
happens I'm gonna get this party started
and I would do the curly shuffle from
the three studio Wow I was a [__] DJ
was the coolest person isn't it funny
that when you become a grown-up all the
people they thought were cool you're
losers they're like wanting a limousine
ladies there was nothing more than dude
limo bar in the back like so great a
limo with your coolest but now you're
like it's so wack
right a limos the war it's all dirty
there's always barf oh you're some
Midwest calm because I'm gonna stop mode
and pick you up and you're like please
don't please don't it's a civic spine
just have the bar back pick me up man
lights Oh but dude so you know who we
used to see is kind of messed up
was that kid from Diff'rent Strokes um
Sam oh okay we were [__] up to him
like people would throw fries on him and
stuff cuz they were jealous I think
that's kind of wack but it was kind of
fun to see him okay so first off
Diff'rent Strokes reference perfect huge
nothing TV was my life get me - yeah
everything yeah I remember when I was
nine I saved up enough money to buy my
own TV and I was like finally and then
today I just wrote a note to myself cuz
I don't know if you guys ever at
thunderstorms or anything here but back
east especially then your cable could go
out your TV could go out I'd be like or
if there was a presidential debate I'm
like why is it on this channel it's on
this channel oh no what happened to my
glorious TV what was your favorite show
different strokes during that time but
was he when miss Mattie was on Diff'rent
Strokes it's probably as good as it got
and then Sam being that next that's such
a great cliche let's introduce a young
care order to pump new life and that kid
got fries thrown at him yeah at the
skating rink at Skateland it's kind of
wack but again it was jealousy in
retrospect people were like dude you
think you're better than us he's you're
on Diff'rent Strokes and he wasn't he
wasn't mean at all I feel so bad I know
I think you're better that was one of
the funniest characters Adam Sandler
ever did it was just a guy on cider life
that was just getting to a crime scene
girl do you think you're better than me
everybody so sad on the inside I really
think you know farce dumped her hand
across the country I think I'm just
gonna go and hug everybody until it's
okay like that's everybody has that
anger that that feeling of like I'm not
good enough for this so how am I gonna
hurt
that's what nobody wants to get
vulnerable that's why everybody's angry
it's why poor Sam it's like hey guys I'm
on TV it's good what could go wrong
we're gonna get mom dropped me and the
guys off I'm gonna go meet my fans
that's escape everybody hates me
how does that but some people we didn't
like chunk adored
everybody loved chunk the coolest person
sama koco's he had a wacky hat on like
he was a dream who's so cute you know
he's a lawyer now
yeah yeah he was like student class
president in there Berkeley a smart guy
yeah I would like to meet him and figure
out what what went okay like you hear so
many sad stories about kids that were
actors yeah for sure and or how they
just crash and burn but he didn't look
he's like a real professional with a
real life it might be one of those
things where you luck out on one super
role and maybe he couldn't look at like
that role was cartoony and but it was
such a caricature a cartoon role yeah
it's not like how do you cast chunk in
something maybe maybe he couldn't get
work again you know who knows yeah a lot
of those kids like data what happened to
data movie was so good
can I say you my favorite movie yes
please there's quite a few six summer
movies were the best in the valley
cuz that's you had to go to the movie
theater to cool off okay summer movies
Valley how old are you when you stuck on
a movie theater by yourself how are you
getting there what are some of the first
movies you remember by yourself
by myself you know twelve you know you
know there's smoke cigarettes may be
cool be cool that'd be seen yeah
you just went there to like strut your
[__] right like where your cool jeans
see kids from other schools oh my god
that girls were in a pen cross field
hockey jacket she's so hot the girls
there are so much hotter than the girls
old school remember Alyssa Milano do I
who didn't want to be Alyssa Milano oh
the hottest chick ever the most
embarrassing story I have about Alyssa
Milano this is a true stuff okay I
didn't after college I moved back in
with my parents because obviously I'm
not the type of guy that's gonna get his
life together
so I remember this was back home
Blockbuster Video was still a thing my
dad loved that place and he would always
come home with a bag of movies with a
sense of pride and joy
like like a Papa Bear coming home with a
kill like this is what I have to provide
my family okay uh-huh and he's coming
with the bag and he'd have everybody
gather around like he was a bad magician
he would go into the bag okay first off
I got a picture we can all enjoy ladies
and gentlemen sure yeah there's
old-timey words are funny right and you
use them at a picture we can all join
supposed to be a four-star film a little
something called Dumb and Dumber and
like and then he would and then he be
like I got a picture that me and her
mother are gonna enjoy it's a woman's
picture I don't think you guys and then
number one so he's going through his bag
and he pulls out like three movies and
he looks at me he goes hey buddy that's
so painful hey buddy there's a little
something I figured you might enjoy you
know well me and your mom go upstairs I
got a list of Milano it was like poison
ivy - oh yeah it was like here we go
buddy enjoy it and I was like I'm gonna
go jump until what you mortifying and
pi2 was not as good as pi-1 let's be
honest I just remember Alyssa Milano
Havenstein one of the first jokes ever
wrote was about oh really
yeah how Tony Danza had to be hitting on
her do you think well that was like my
crazy like before I got more personal
comedy we had bad morning radio don't
you think Tony Danza was like Samantha
what am I gonna you know and then I
would get filthy it's like I was so
dirty she was she was the gold standard
her and that girl from Charles and Joe
Eggert yeah come on man yeah they were
the one two of hotness in the ninth
that's as hot as you could be those two
I wanted to be those two was like oh my
god
um but hold on the movie that kind of
changed my life
uh-huh let's talk about it I thought it
was probably the funniest most creative
movie there's a lot of those in the 80s
um gremlins amazing amazing yeah even
gremlins - not so bad
Hulk Hogan in the movie theater gremlins
was so okay
I really thought gremlins was real so no
I wanted a Mogwai yes like I was like I
remember there would be like before the
internet I used to do a joke about this
before the internet you just had Olly
pick up your knowledge on the streets
yes and I remember like moto brother
second sales rates Anthony Scotto has
got an uncle in Japan he's connected he
was at a party once poor tamakwa turned
into a gremlin and like we'd really
those stupid little kid things we're
like yeah why why isn't there gremlins
of course yeah we were spoiled the
movies who I feel bad for kids now I
feel Saxon it sucks and I'm sorry I know
it like people like know they have I'm
like what do they have they have all
this stuff we had yet Star Wars we're
Raiders of the Lost Ark we had gremlins
wid Goonies we had ghostbusters
Ghostbuster best stuff ever looks so
funny dude I used to watch those movies
on a loop when that cable TV memorized
yeah I know all of those I can't quote
Shakespeare but I can pull Peter Venkman
yes this is true
this man has no dick funniest thing ever
my favorite is symmetrical book stacking
just like to Philadelphia case of 1865
you're right right no human being could
stack books like this so great so good
spies like us oh um what about doctor
doctor doctor doctor I just did that
joke to somebody just did that yesterday
honestly on it it though there what's
that Revenge of the Nerds flawless well
there's not a point where I won't cry
this is how I know if I still have my
soul if I see the end of Revenge of the
Nerds and it doesn't make me go I'm just
thinking about it
oh my god right when Lewis Skolnick
grabs the mic yeah oh it's so great and
I love one of his fraternity brothers
have his back up a bow bow bow leave the
kid alone
Bernie case here ever was it's so good
hands everybody and everybody clap your
hands
oh it's so good Lamarr Laurette yeah
Laurette Lamarr electric violin do you
know yet and now comes a land of three
feet tall break oh and I think
booger Dudley Dawson can I tell you this
many celebrities I've seen in LA I saw a
booger at Gelson's about did your heart
stop I [__] lost my mind yeah it's
amazing
how I remember seeing Willie Aames once
drive by in a late model BMW I couldn't
believe it like that was as cool as it
got well Booker was so funny okay for
instance there's that wonderful Belcher
why do they call you booger it is like I
don't know timing perfect timing face
perfect but the belching contest awesome
genius because he does he rips that long
burp and then he does a smiles
self-approval bit it's so subtly perfect
everything I don't think and there were
so many storylines there's so many
layers everything pays off
everything's character driven they uh
who wrote that I don't know but they
don't know how to write like that any
note yeah
thought I was looking at my mom's old
douche bag but I left that back in
Cleveland how about when they go try to
fight why are you here I'm here about
the room for our body what do you I was
such a good way I got the old cruise
control set of 35 every character it's
so good because that was a time where
you could make inappropriate jokes at
the expense of gay people or women or yo
yeah we're so uptight right now where it
really is like a form of thought control
I really do believe it it's like you
know what I'm old-school liberal I'm
like a cou 80s style like hey he's got a
right to do it I don't have to agree
with it he's got a right to say it and
when people start policing comedy and
humor that's really scary that's what
the Communists were doing when my dad
was in Hungary growing up your dad grew
up in Hong Li yeah both my parents
escaped from communist Hungary and oh my
god they're the people now like I worked
at a gym in Hollywood where was all
people from Russia Ukraine form its
Soviet bloc now like this country's
going down the tube that's my dad say
yeah they see it they see this yes
that's what my dad says he's like this
is
no good this is how it was before the
Russians yes that's the hair of my arms
is standard how do we stop this um
making jokes right I guess you got to
fight the power man 1989 another summer
I mean look at Lenny Bruce like he was
the first one of us to bang down that
door and you know it's just it's just
gonna have to be another Lenny Bruce
revival we're all gonna have to band
together and resist I don't know that's
crazy yeah because when you think about
a joke yeah there's nothing more
altruistic than the intention behind a
joke well you're like hey man I'm trying
to make you laugh yeah and you're
disagreeing scary it's really Julia did
somebody tweet at you saying that it was
racially insensitive yeah I'm the victim
here right you tell me that but person
of color can't be a bully we're right
well that's the obviously people
listening don't know the story is I grew
up in the valley during into this
integration program LA Unified with
busing kids from like South Central from
their gang and they're essentially a lot
of gang bangers that got bus into myself
and I got into fights a lot with like
black girls yeah that's just how was
they used to [__] with me because I was
white yep and were you really a goth by
the way that's so core goth and we
fought and I fought back but I pushed
the [__] back on this girl often and I
got a respect and we were cool like
that's the whole point of story is that
Marty McFly yes for yourself yeah have
to instead of this horseshit about well
let's try to stop bullying good luck
because there's always gonna be bullies
you got to learn how to [__] do the
world's most perfect I wish it was I am
like one of those I look I really wish
everybody knew that they were loved and
lovable and usually did everybody great
I really wish that but I'm smart enough
to go that's not how it works and you
know what
there's a certain purpose to bully I
hate to sound crazy about it but it's
like it gives you that choice like hey
I'm either gonna stand up or I want to
take it which is a huge choice but then
there's also like the worst stuff of my
life has always led to the best things
and it's like worse like honestly I
could a see
DC were good-looking guys and got a lot
of chicks we wouldn't have their music
today you know seriously like I think
the reason why that so many of those 80s
movies were so well written and directed
is because those guys didn't have a lot
of friends growing up so they hung out
with their nerd friends and made each
other laugh and change the world nerds
people victims become the strong
absolutely you know it's like absolutely
there's a beauty to that - it's like
drummer me [__] like remembers there
was an awesome episode of happy days
where Fonzie pulled this push this guy
off the swings and it was Tom Hanks came
back as a cameo on happy days as a
karate expert and was like the only
person that beat up Fonzie shut up he
like karate kicked Fonzie through a wall
but then father used his Fonzie powers
and came back and then they squashed it
he was the only person to give Fonzie a
fight do you know I mean I don't know if
you've written on many shows before I
want to oh well there's this not sign
yet man but but that's what's called the
Fonzie character now in every sitcom
it's like Kramer
yes but they didn't expect Fonzie to be
that takeoff thing and then you have a
spin-off show okay this is what I
remember from Happy Days spin-off Mork
and Mindy
everybody forgets that [__] love more
committee best show yes Robin Williams
always at the end what he learns that's
what I'm gonna bring back that what I
learned I don't care people make fun of
me and call me like a sit I don't care I
want to bring back that Michael Landon
that highway to heaven the episode where
the little homeless kids got his cat I'm
seven crying like can somebody give give
this kid the huggy Mork always learning
lessons let's what happened to art
trying to bring out the best in people I
know I think because now we're so hosed
there's so much information that the
truth is hard to find the truth is we
don't know where it's located anymore so
right and that's why there's so many
voices that they have to break through
the [__] there's too much [__]
right now that's why
back then we were kids there was what
channels 2 4 5 7 9 11 13 that was your
information yeah and the newspaper and
then yeah but now it's overwhelming and
nobody knows what to believe you know I
don't even fault like I you know in your
Facebook feed there's all kinds of
ridiculous stories like I don't even
know what's truly yeah yeah why bother I
can't even follow it all like that's
yeah so confusing and I don't watch the
news anymore I was like oh that's one
way to keep myself in a good mood
I don't watch don't watch I don't watch
the news at all but then yeah you open
up social media like Twitter is kind of
like I get on that in the morning it
bums me out and I'm I can't
yeah I can't look at Twitter until I've
had coffee until I've like gotten in a
better place emotionally because you
will get sabotage I'll get sabotage by
those those shitty tweets it you know
like [__] you [__] this is that and
you're like oh I I should have waited
the social media do sorry but back today
before I forget it Fonzie character no
decorating your locker oh my gosh you're
two for two with unbelievable callbacks
right now really how did you decorate
your locker well I'm at this point I
don't even do kids still have lockers
they have to have laughing they do
because of security I thought I think
kids carry everything with them you know
that's what I've heard
isn't it on a laptop or I don't know
yeah I don't know it's on a chip in
their heads now they just read their own
babies well fully goth I mean I was it's
a lot of Robert Smith a lot of Joy
Division I didn't start doing that until
7 3/8 grade so that's when everything
changes yeah that's like yeah dark side
of the force yeah yeah yeah like wanting
to fit in wanting to connect people
realizing a sad part of human nature
where they're like oh I know to make
myself feel better or seem important I
need to poop on somebody else we need to
start excluding divide and conquer
click-click elementary school I didn't
like waking up and going to school but
it was pretty cool like I loved I have a
whole bit now in homeroom parties I love
the fact that everybody was invited
right everybody was invited yeah and it
goes back to all the stuff about moms I
won't get to that hopefully before the
end I think that's the most important
job in the world
did you know did you guys do this I
don't know if you did this but in LA
because rainy days were so seldom you
would stay in during recess and play
heads up seven up the best game ever the
best game ever so much fun so much fun I
would do that
now me too why don't we play that at the
Comedy Store we should Doc's like there
is I think wait no oh no heads up seven
a bit difficult but there's a lot of
different fun games I'm saying yeah red
light green lights rad heads-up
something you put your thumb up and they
have to guess there's seven people
standing in the front and if you guess
who pushed your thumb down good I was
such a [__] it could be like that
obvious Matt Matt no is it Matt son of
it like I would never get it right and
when I did I felt like I want a game
show game like you could tell by the
pressure and if someone's hand was
sweaty and like I heard we're doing it
so gently yeah the gods take your girl
or think yes like I look at their shoes
like you can't cheat like you cheated
playing heads up seven up well right now
and then you got a win everyone small
dude what about test taking time when
you put your [__] folders up did you
put your PG folders like wait were you
that nerd do it like you will not cheat
off of me yeah oh my god that's so great
how about summer movies remember that
movie summer school undertaking yeah
that's just go and see see see see so
Mark Harmon the best yeah what happened
to Mark Harmon I don't know him and that
guy that played a sledgehammer remember
him wasn't he like was he Max Headroom
no great sledgehammer
I'm thinking of that's a different actor
some white guy blond hair
so good but I think we're forgetting the
mother of all or Top Gun not the best
remember this kid Mike James loved that
movie so much he wanted to go on to the
main
to fly planes me and my brothers were
like we watch that we didn't love it
though whaling is kind of I'd rather
watch commando bro
commando yeah seen that a million times
too I remember I have to bring this joke
back you're parking all these things
where I'm like oh I just have a joke
about my mom was so good at pretending
that she was in the stuff to get out of
stuff does that make sense
like I remember specifically like my dad
us being old enough where he could just
take us to the movies and it was like
predator or something and my mom had a
choice I come to predator or have the
house to herself for three hours he's
like baby are you sure yeah my feeling
to it now I'm like she just wanted to I
ate for three hours so remember my dad
coming in the house like a child babe
you got I gotta get in the car I'm gonna
take you to go see this look Arnold did
it again I don't know how he did it but
it's phenomenal
it's a classic he has so much money I
was listening to him on Howard Stern
mm-hmm Arnold Schwarzenegger just he's a
billionaire I mean he made so many
killer movies he lied into the Kennedy
family like investments he bought Santa
Monica up when he was still a
bodybuilder dude guys unbelievable I
don't think money makes people happy
though I think that's the biggest lie I
think it's certainly you need a certain
level to absolutely have you're gonna be
able to pay your bills and I definitely
have more than I have I need to get to
the point where it's like not every
month like should I buy a scratch-off
and see if I can make it you don't want
to think about money that's how much
money you should have to where you don't
really have to think about it every day
yes but then I think some people they
have so much money that's all they think
about yes that makes sense yep
like I don't want to lose it it's this
guy trying to get my money they become
like Scrooge McDuck yeah it gets can too
much consuming it's like right in the
middle you need that balance of
everything yeah I agree I want if you
make a money but you live below your
means I think that's that's great that's
what you're supposed to do I don't like
stuff per se I'm not a stuff person but
I like the idea of having money in the
bank in case I get sensitive it's just
like my have food in the fridge yes I
like walking into my kitchen some
times like to cheer myself up I just
gonna need that and then I'm gonna eat
that wait I might eat this that I might
eat that or oh you know what I'll do
I'll go to Ralph's real fast I'm gonna
get some sriracha so then that way I'm
gonna put it with it I look at their
combinations of delicious food in my
head
I love the brook groats if I don't if I
have to give up comedy I'm getting a job
at the supermarket oh because I love
people and I love food and I go there
everyday what I do pretty much - it's
the greatest joy honey we were looking
at our credit card bill statement and
it's like a forensic detail of my house
it's all like Albertsons Albertsons
Albertsons it's so great yeah
iTunes itunes what got you something
what got you into uh-huh it's my little
buddy the kid I go visit buddy yeah this
little kid named he's not doing so great
so once soon as you started - what's the
word self-actualize right soon as you
started to you get in the middle school
and you become a goth and you have all
this you have like this depressing
locker with all that like extras of the
cure and those punk bands all that stuff
mm-hmm so I was a skateboarder middle
school and that could go one of two
directions there were the kids that were
like into punk rock and like it was
weird I didn't really understand that
kind of music until I hit my quarter
life crisis and then I remember like
typing on myspace I came an if I ever
made fun of you for listening to this
cuz it just made me feel so much better
I don't know why sad music sometimes
makes you feel good
wanna know why and punk rock because
it's so real and it's there's so much
said in it I think like like I listen to
Dead Kennedys that was my first band
when I was like that was my okay
I remember there was this preacher on TV
he was awesome we I don't know why we
loved it so much but there was this guy
named Pastor Gary who explained why
heavy metal and punk rock music was
tools of the devil and we would just
like watch it and get paranoid like
because of Pastor Gary we had Jason
showers burn in our barbecue in the back
we burned a copy of Ozzy Osbourne's bark
at the moon so we thought we were gonna
see demons fly out of it and like the
plastic did make a little noise because
it was plastic burning I'm a little by
the sight oh my god that's the devil
could you hear like because Pastor Gary
said and then that can these were
supposed to be really bad
well the Dead Kennedys taught you about
subversion they taught you about
politics they talk about [__] like
the stuff the 80s were very I think
we're in another 80s right now like a
very conformist materialistic you know
shopping therapy and it's so superficial
but what happened after the 80s was the
90s which was grunge and a little more a
little more real but yeah dude that
whole thing about like remember [__]
playing records backwards yeah it was a
satanic yeah dude there was one on
Purple Rain remember at the end I'm
already getting scared again can you
talk about this stuff we stayed up to
midnight and we played purple running
backwards yeah what was it on propor now
infer it's the end of I think the song
Purple Rain at the very very end if you
play it backwards but it's not evil he
says the Lord is coming soon the Lord is
coming soon like cuz he's a pretty as
you jehovah's witness I have no princess
princess really oh yeah but um but it's
about Christ it's not about like what
I'm sure there's bad stuff fun to only
talks about a girl's masturbating I
don't remember darling Nikki that was
like the forever punches and hot chicks
in all his movies of course
Apollonia so hot Purple Rain dude that
was like my sexual awakening movie where
you were like wait a minute happening
what is there's a girl topless and it's
in a movie like you I feel bad for kids
now the Internet's really robbed so much
joy of discovery yeah like everything's
right there I like there was a certain
excitement that I don't like being like
a little boy and you're watching a
comedy an r-rated comedy you're already
having the greatest time of your life as
good as life gets
they throw boobs on top of it you're
just like give me the pistol it's never
gonna get better
seeing boobs in a movie was made it so
much more fun well free out for you guys
for us for me it was confusing like wait
the story was fine why are there ways
Cotuit us yeah
wait why we have to show her underwear
in the scene um interest yeah it kind of
didn't it never made sense yeah it's
weird
this conversation come full circle
because it's weird how everything of pop
culture influences like gender roles and
what you expect to yourself and what
what yeah about there I was watching
some action film like I'm [__]
canneries doing something and they
pulled a woman out of an elevator that
was about to like fall mhm
and it was so gratuitous like they
pulled her out and then you just got
like a panty shot like why you know like
we that doesn't add to the story like
why do I happen even with Revenge of the
Nerds like there's so many gratuitous
tits and that absolutely it always made
me feel weird as a kid like we worried
why do I have to seat is right now yeah
there's no reason for it it's so much
fun you just blew my mind what did you
just say there's no reason for it right
yeah it really works without it yeah
doesn't serve any purpose I'm thinking
of that okay when I get insecure onstage
it's the only time I curse oh yeah like
I feel like yeah I don't need it it's a
habit to tick I'm like if I'm if it's a
great crowd and I'm a tease I don't need
to do it you know what because it
doesn't help you know what yes thank you
No can I bring up another very important
thing you want this is yours I'm talking
too much I had called no.4 listeners I
apologize I Drive down here I did it the
same thing on your podcast I feel
terrible no I grabbed a Red Bull before
and then I get Chadi Chadi check ok
Slurpees the greatest versus icees let's
suck on those nuts well the greatest
thing about icees was that they were
available at snack bars in stores I did
not want to be
so I have a bit now about how little
kids are gangsters and we would shake my
mom down for things hmm like we would
use like intimidation what's the word or
it's a we would extort my mom like you
want me to behave we're gonna get a
jawbreaker and I see and she big net and
then grabbing my little brother when we
would just hide I used to play
hide-and-go-seek with my mom without her
knowing we were playing I used to love
to hear the panic in her voice and then
I knew it was time to come out from our
hiding spot when we would get paged on
the intercom what Stephen and marks mom
please report to their mother she's at
the snack bar and am I forgetting
snacks bro dicks okay I know you threw
your mom into a panic dude often it came
back to me full circle and that my
nephew did that to me once he freaked I
choked the [__] out of my kid if he does
that to me I'm he's gonna he's gonna
think it's the funniest thing in the
world yeah yes one of the best things I
saw was on the beach I was living in
Santa Monica everything's perfect and I
see these two ladies off in the distance
and these little guys they're like three
or four sprinting full-speed away from
their moms and like they have that
little wall along the beach it's like
out on a two feet high three little kids
hop over the wall and then they just
duck down and I'm like what's gone and
the little kid looks at me because we're
hiding from our mom people kind of is
dafuq with your parents cuz it's like a
form of power as a kid because you have
so little power intrusive that I think
it's your one way of revenge of like
[__] you I'm in control of this right
now I'm gonna hide yeah you're
absolutely right yeah yeah you excited
to be a mom yeah I am actually I'm
really ready I you're gonna be the last
mom ever
you really are you and Tom that's so
cool
they have it's like reminds me like Ben
Stiller you know what I mean his parents
we're comedian right you know what I
mean like
your kids are gonna be so cool I hope I
mean I don't know if my kids like I want
to be a comedian I don't know how you
know will you feel like you did your job
or did not do your job if your kids said
they want to be a comedian
you know honestly because my the reason
I'm a comic is for dark [__] yeah I came
from bad things it didn't come from joy
so I don't know my husband's a comic
because he came from a good family and
he just likes to make people laugh but
yes um I would feel like it was some
kind of a failure yeah at least from me
my motives are totally dark and weird
and so but he can do whatever the [__]
he wants and I gotta tell my kid you
know I don't care as long as he's
healthy and not a sociopath or a killer
you know hooked on drugs or whatever
just lead any kind of productive life
that's all I ask
yeah that's awesome just be productive
dude just give to the world give back
that's awesome right isn't that it's not
while you can home for with people yeah
just don't be a douche bag it just yeah
be [__] mean shitty to people it's
that simple way yeah don't be a douche
each time we've been talking for oh my
god
we're almost at an hour already oh my
god flies by I said I love talking about
this childhood [__] it's fun right so
much fun dude wait the ultimate yep
slippers life oh yeah how much fun was
that [__] how do people not snap
themselves in half we did you'd you
would like land on sprinklers and break
your back and eat grass okay
so dangerous the difference between
being a child and an adult in terms of
recovery time back in July I got very
excited over a burrito I'm not making
this up very excited over a burrito I
slipped off the curb just a 4-inch curb
and my ankle twisted just enough that
was the weekend after the fourth of July
and we're now in October and I'm just
able to start doing cardio again but a
slip inside like you slide into
somebody's driveway you're one scab from
your tootsies up to your neck yeah dude
you would run on a lawn full speed like
you're standing running and then you
would somehow plop down on your belly
on a hard I break my neck right and then
it was like the NFL Combine it's like
everybody's ready to go oh yeah I've
definitely a theme that's constantly
come up in this podcast which leads me
to believe that guardian angels are 100%
real and they have to work overtime with
kids yeah there's so many instances
there there's no way just your everyday
thing as a kid there's no how do you how
do you survive I don't know just riding
your bicycle like I think back to how
reckless we all were little kid brains
we used to ride our bikes in like the LA
wash like you know in Greece where they
raise our eyes but that's that's where
we would play like in a dangerous ass
wash yeah diseases floating around there
and like how do we know bows with rusty
knife yeah and not get kidnapped or
stolen I mean now kids can't run the
streets it's a you know they arrest you
if you let your kid even walk to the
park alone yeah that's true that's not
an exaggeration you can't even have a
lemonade stand anymore what happened to
this country you can't have a lemonade
no no there are different townships that
are legitimately writing tickets and
fines for operating businesses without
proper license your quarter a cup of
[__] unbelievable
did you were you in the Boy Scouts did
you do that I could see you liking that
no I'm not good at fitting in with stuff
but it's funny everybody says I'm a Boy
Scout now yeah and I'm like yeah I'm
totally a Boy Scout now yeah but I hate
it what's that that's your next album
cover Boy Scout I hated anybody tell me
what to do like I was like when I was a
little kid I was gangster I was like oh
yeah is that what you want me to do how
about you go [__] yourself
even if it was something I wanted to do
see I don't that is so funny cuz you you
have two layers who you know that like
is happy and there's it's great and then
you have this undercurrent of like gold
fog yeah absolutely and then I dig
deeper and then that's where the real
good stuff is
like on the surface I'm like okay this
is my choice I want to choose to be
happy I'm gonna choose to be kind I'm
gonna choose and then the level below
that I'm like don't make me do this and
then the level below that it's just like
hey man God's real we're here to be a
source of his love enjoying acceptance
for everybody and that's where I pulled
myself out of my darkness was tapping
into that and when I tap into that
everything's cool but when I get to that
second level of my pure humanity where
I'm like this isn't fair and I start to
get fear and doubt and it's not a good
place to be but I'm able to recognize it
now that's huge yeah and I'm like okay
look what you're doing get back into the
moment now hear this
well plus it's your triggers your
childhood [__] that's being activated
for sure and you're like something oh
like that guy tweeting me like activated
some-some kink from childhood thing so I
mean it like at the end of the day it's
fine I don't care what people you know
you can have an opinion about what I say
like I don't big deal but yeah it
activates your brain and then your brain
goes off yeah and then you're like wait
why am I giving this stranger I've never
met this much more to rob me of this joy
of being alive step back from all of it
and you're like yeah this is all miracle
we're floating on some planet around
some star dude that's like I'm gonna let
some sad look sad people try to make
everybody feel bad it's that simple I
can I tell you what I've discovered like
you realize that there's a woman that
grew you and that grew everybody
everyone has to be just stated by
another person yes and it starts just
two cells and then I have to sit here
for nine months I don't I don't mind it
it's been great but like yeah the
absolute improbability of your existence
to begin with and the fact that you
survived out of billions and billions of
sperm and yeah countless eggs
yeah and that your mother was
successfully just stated you and then
you were successfully birthed yes it's
that alone miracle [__] miraculous
miracles so much [__] can go wrong
everyday with this like I just rip fall
down the stairs there goes my miracles
yeah I don't know we started to talk
I don't think we were recording but I
remember being on stage two years two
years ago maybe three now at the Comedy
Store the night before Mother's Day and
uh
I knew I remember like one year I was
out here and I forgot about Mother's Day
I know that's terrible but I was working
so much I was so poor I had so many
terrible minimum-wage jobs I was just
you know but I didn't I was like oh my
god it's Mother's Day so I didn't have
money to send anything but I got the
phone call in and then now years later
I'm on stage at the Comedy Store like
there might be somebody out there in the
crowd tonight
that forgot tomorrow's Mother's Day or I
was like what if there's people that did
remember it's Mother's Day and they
brought their mom to a comedy show
nobody thanked moms in the crowd nobody
so I'm like I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
do that because it's Mother's Day and I
remember him when I did that like I did
it in the middle of my set I lost half
the room and I'm like what's happened to
society when we don't appreciate moms
like I was saying 15 20 years ago if
you're like give it up for moms would
have been the most patronizing easy
comedy and now it's countercultural it's
Sabrosa for your like because I think
we're just such a selfish Society people
don't want to ever say I needed this
person in my life and they never want to
live for somebody else and I really
getting back to your whole concept of
miracle if your mother was just a person
that brought you into this world if
there was just a woman that gave birth
to you and she lived on top of a
mountain and you the only thing she did
was give you life let alone shape who
you are and care for you and make sure
you survived but just the person that
brought you into this world if that was
their only job you wouldn't you should
have the desire and the sense of
responsibility to travel around the
world like Mecca and well I'm a mountain
top and go thank that person for giving
you this chance to be alive at least
once in your life yeah exactly yeah and
it's such a crazy sacrifice and
I don't think um we should be leading
things as far as I know offense of the
the men the white guys that control the
world but it's like wait a minute I
[__] created oh yeah
like my body created the white man [__]
am i doing in second place everything
yeah dude without me and understand I
need a sperm yeah but come on let's be
real the bulk of the [__] gets done by
the women and it's hard it's you suffer
for nine months it's not like any he's
all of it like I think if jeez that's
why I think or society's in trouble
because we don't appreciate moms the way
we used to
well a lot of that too that is one of
the flaws of the women's movement is
that this the thing of not respecting
the stay-at-home mom there's AI there's
a did you I don't know if you know this
but in the mom world mm-hmm there's a
rift between working moms and
stay-at-home moms I no idea I know I'm
just learning about it yeah like I'm
really not in into it yet but there's a
huge rift and the stay-at-home moms
present the working moms working moms I
don't know how they feel about the
stay-at-home moms but yeah because of
because of that and sanho moms are seen
is not I guess contributing to society
because they don't bring home an income
but it's so dumb so does they're raising
humans like you're the most people
reason why everybody's a jerk right yeah
it's because they don't have anybody
raise them
nobody's they don't know right from
wrong and they don't feel loved they
don't feel worthy of love like I think a
mom's job is well Anna dads - yeah oh
absolutely absolutely yeah not just like
Jesus Christ it's a team effort
I passed gotta be has to be but that's
something the pendulum hasn't swung now
so the working mom suffers the pendulum
needs to go to where mom and dad do
equal as far as I can start raising the
kid absolutely why do i why am I the
only one that has to take a hit and stay
home right like like my husband's gonna
be taking down maternity leave to be
with me that's all because we can
because we're we work for ourselves and
we can thank God and yeah and it wasn't
like it was it was a very rational thing
like we why wouldn't a May
want to be there for the first two
months of that baby's life yeah what is
the bond and connect yeah what's cooler
than a baby yeah and your baby and if
you don't think if you don't do it that
kid grows up to be a [__] psycho
lunatic and being sociable when I see
people that sacrificed family time for
money
those kids always have problems and
always and I'm saying I know most people
don't have that decision sadly like you
know people have to work and they have
to pay bills solutely but it's like I
feel bad that there's no like where's
the affordable housing or like right and
just be like hey there's just
millionaires now and everybody else and
it sucks there's no more middle class
but I see these kids that grew up with
nannies and they got BMWs from their 17
yeah and they're the saddest people I've
ever met
yeah and those wounds never get repaired
no there's no replacement for mom and
dad no she's not and and by the way
that's not to say that everyone can and
should be able to take off two months no
that's what I'm saying like you can't
and I'm aware of that that my absolutely
this reality position you're blessed
believe me
yeah it's I'm very thankful that our
careers ended up this way that I can but
like I don't know how do women do it how
do women how do you have a baby and then
immediately have to go back it's
terrible terrible or even the poor women
that have to stand on their feet or
they're pregnant like wait tables eight
months pregnant I don't know whenever I
see a pregnant woman or a mom with a
little bit I'm like I get a little
nervous to be honest and I'm like
whatever I can do to help like I saw mom
the other day with a baby trying to get
it the baby into the car and I'm like
how can I help and she was like oh my
god you know she told me to thank my mom
she was like tell your mother she did a
good job and I was like whatever you
guys were so sweet at our ease taping
haha can I help you do you want a plate
of fruit do you want anything yeah yeah
are so protective it was really sweet
how everybody should be you know I think
soon as we all realize that we're all
connected you know my favorite quote
that I've been thinking about over and
over again that makes me feel better
was Mother Teresa and I'm paraphrasing
Mother Teresa
she said the biggest problem facing
society today is that we forgot that we
belong to each other
mm-hmm and I'm like yep mm-hmm there's
only one of us here really we're all
made of the same star dust dude yes same
[__] just different forms different
blobs we're not there's no difference in
the home you and I go through the same
crap same stuff
no except you're a white guy that's
pretty great you would think you really
would think you're like top of the food
chain bro it's pretty good thing be
president stuff
not at my height nobody would ever take
me seriously nobody no reason take a man
of my stature all right I don't want to
take up any more thank you me this was
the best thank you so much yeah thank
you so much for coming down here
what are your the two podcasts that
you're on and where can people find them
um well your mom's house I do with my
husband Tom Segura one of the funniest
guys ever he is so funny he's doing
another Netflix special yeah yeah he
taped it and then it's we don't know
when it's gonna release but look out for
that be like how it came out yeah
awesome he was so he was so stoked and
he filmed this little short in front of
it that's gonna be awesome too so oh so
cool yeah so keep it I love the short in
front of the stand-ups yeah it happened
to that dice had a great one Eddie
Murphy had a great one and they all do
in classic he wanted to save the
surprise yeah and then that's deep bro
which is the thing I do by myself and I
Steve Simone's been a guest and we
discuss happiness yeah that was great
you wanna hear Steve's episode check out
that's deep bro this was the best thank
you so much
but what a great name for a website
Christina's website yeah it's just
thousand drenched calm I think it's a
two favorite salad dressing that's
hysterical
dude her and Tom are so cool they're
gonna be cool parents the coolest
parents I hope I just I'm sure they
won't but I just imagine them like what
if they suddenly had the kid in another
really like uptight people but I don't
think that's gonna happen not at all
dude they're such cool people that it
makes me want to have a baby so then
they could be friends with their baby oh
yeah that'd be so fun
plus I was hanging out with run is easy
and the boys on Sunday how is that the
moat
it's the most fun there is in life but
you know what I don't beat myself up for
it cuz I remember I left Philly 15 years
ago because I couldn't find a chick that
like wanted to be treated right you know
what I mean oh yeah I was like oh god
these girls all like one awful dudes so
I was like you know what it's not gonna
happen so at least try try to be go be a
comedian but it's like being a comedian
is great but just hanging out with
family that's the most fun you can have
right like his kids run his Easy's kids
are in the glory years there's so much
fun to hang out with we were playing
this game called GUI Louie what's that
where you have to pick boogies out of
this guy's nose the human nose or Lily's
nose it's a toy oh I think it's right
like you just go up to like different
peoples at the houses you know no no you
wanted to pick people you could pick
your friends and you can pick your nose
but you can't pick your friends nose
amber when Dan can Allen said that I
thought it was the funniest thing ever
wait was that I don't know I was way I
was way not it wasn't like second grade
it was like tenth grade I've never
matured what's the point of maturing mmm
I don't know well I will say this I have
insured like I'm all about like handling
my business and living for other people
and I think that's what a man does you
know what I mean like you go this is
what I want but this is what serves the
greater good and your job as a man is to
serve the greater good
uh but I'm not like a miserable grown-up
like I like to have fun who doesn't like
to have fun
plenty of people lets us sad yeah it is
sad like I had to beat up a couple
audiences at the Comedy Store this
weekend well I'm like why do you come
out if you don't want to have fun I'm
just like you're missing the whole point
of life and like I'm starting to write
all these bits about that because what
it is in my opinion people are
profoundly scared of what life being
vulnerable connecting acting like they
enjoy themselves
like you'll see people just everybody's
miserable they all have the tough-guy
face on they're profoundly selfish they
don't hold the door open for people they
don't say please they don't say thank
you they don't engage with other people
and now that behaviors creeping in the
comedy clubs where people are like you
can't make me laugh bro
and I'm like I don't want to what's the
point man what's the point but it's sad
you know the people that need the hug
the most rather wants to deserve it the
least you know what I'm saying was it
the same way when you started or is do
you think it's new not snow
people are getting sadder that's why we
need to focus on the good times you have
more laughs and be nicer to each other I
need ice cream and eat ice cream have
you thought about the question I asked
you
yeah and I've had a lot of people like
professionally and like who have had
impact but I if I had to pick one person
I'm gonna say my mom cuz that I was
lucky enough to have a stay-at-home mom
for the majority of my life and yeah and
yeah I would have to say that the
majority of like my the way I was raised
and and the beliefs that I have are from
my mom I mean we don't agree on
everything like when I walked in we were
on the phone and she was she was telling
me something and I you could just see
that my blood pressure was rising just
cuz there's no one like a mom to do that
to you but for sure I would yeah like
the way I try to treat people and the
way that I that she taught me to just
just even do my homework in school yeah
it's just you know what I always come
back to that as a reference point where
I'm like there's two types of people in
the world there's people that did their
homework and there's people that didn't
oh yeah I really believe that man I was
both at different points in my life
man I see people or a mic you never you
got nobody to blame but yourself I hate
to break it to people
but life's art and if you know if you
don't have the life that you want start
making changes cuz it's nobody else's
fault right
no yet but then it's also like how could
it like I was lucky enough that my mom
was there if my mom wasn't there yep at
that point they're the people that don't
have the reason the point is the world's
not gonna help right you know maybe you
had a great mom and maybe somebody
didn't maybe maybe somebody grew up with
nothing
but it's like if you want your life to
change sadly you have to be the one that
does it it's really frustrating part how
it's so frustrating and it's like I see
the interconnection between everybody I
tried my best to help everybody and be
as loving and his understanding as
compassionate is helpful like I don't
really have a lot of tangible life
skills but one thing I can't help is
comics or people that want to do
something comedic so if they want to be
a stand-up but they want to write so I'm
like send me your questions like all
these young kids come up to me The
Comedy Store all the time I get emails
all the time from people are like I'm
thinking about my first open mic that I
can do I can help but I tell them I go
it's gonna be a lot of work I'm here to
help but ultimately it's gonna come down
to you and it's hard especially I that
were the people I grew up with we're
very well off like a lot of Apple my
town
sure so then I'll go on Facebook and
I'll see people getting jobs that I know
for like I I look back and I remember
them calling me for homework answers or
them not doing home well yeah and I see
them driving yeah what you're saying was
fixed oh yeah that's a huge part yeah I
remember it is fixed a little yeah I
remember grad like I was Dean so a
student in college I was national
marketing Honor Society all that stuff
yeah for sure and I got one see my
senior that kept me out of being helpful
like Phi Beta Kappa or whatever that is
but I didn't try I just wanted to learn
soon as I stopped focusing on grades and
just focused on paying attention and
going to class that's when I got all A's
and a few B's oh really
yeah it was weird it was injured
thing was like a little paradigm shift
but I remember like being in my senior
year and I'm like this hell naive I was
I was like all the hot chicks I hate to
say it got jobs right away like in
January they got jobs and we were
graduating in May and they're like I
have all these offers and I'm like wait
what I don't even have job interviews
how do you have offers and then all the
kids whose parents can make a phone call
yeah and that's still how the world
works by and large but it's like hey it
is what it is I'm hopeful work hard and
never give up do you think like the
parents who make the phone call
if the kids do a bad job do you think
they still move forward or do you think
they'll make that get that first job and
then it goes south no no no there's it's
like the beginning of Rushmore remember
Bill Murray speech it was like many most
of you here were born rich and you're
gonna die rich that whole thing I don't
watch it oh it's so good it's so good
but that's not the point
like that's the other thing too like
what are we talking about now we're
talking about you're talking about kid
driving BMWs who cares what you drive or
where you live it all comes down to how
you treating other people and how happy
you are right and then that's all
decisions that are all within our
control and I guess maybe that's what I
was saying when I say if you don't like
your life that's your decision you can
make this it even when everything sucks
you could go I could let this break me
or it could go I have a choice to not
let this affect me I have a choice every
we're always presented with a choice
even when somebody stinky and like today
I was on the phone with Bank of America
it was bad but like like oh and I I just
never recommend flying American Airlines
and it's amazing how everybody's sending
me stuff like somebody sent me a video
today of them kicking somebody off a
plane that didn't even deserve to be off
the plane you hear everybody booing on
the plane they're like this is terrible
I'm never flying American Airlines again
boo boo yeah like some awful flight
attendant because what happens is
companies treat their employees like
crap and then the employees treat you
like crap that's just how it works man
yeah that's why I avoid like I'm flying
back to Philly on United any other I am
NOT
look I'm sure there will be times from
forced to fly American when I'm not
paying for the ticket or something else
but number one they're not the best
price I can find a comparable price and
not have to put up with them it's such
an awful experience and today I was on
the phone with Bank of America and they
first up you have to do all your own
customer service yeah you know and I was
trying to figure out their online app I
have an app on my phone and the option I
needed wasn't there so I'm like now I
have to get they put me on hold
then they have me press all these
buttons with a computer I'm not talking
to anybody and I'm like so frustrated
right because I'm just trying to be a
customer they used to have customer
service now I have the app and I have to
be my own customer service person fine
then I call you and you have a computer
asking me the same question I did not
hear you alright oh and yeah I kept
don't do it I was like operator up and
then finally we appreciate your time and
patience I'm like no you don't because
you never have enough people so and then
they finally connect me to somebody that
doesn't speak English right and I'm like
excuse me what I go sir are you speaking
English yeah haha yes I am here I assist
you you need and I'm like um and then I
had a choice and I just my choice was to
start laughing I was like sir is there
anybody in your general vicinity that
speaks English as a first language of
course sir and then I was like I was
like sir I'm not trying to be up not
being rude and I'm not trying to be
disrespectful but I don't I can't
understand anything you're saying
where am i calling and then and then he
was and then when he knew I was cool and
I was in a good mood he's like I'm in
Mexico I go dude I applaud you your
English is good I just can't understand
it we're not gonna accomplish anything
right and then if you tried to go to the
bank it'd be a 45-minute wait to an hour
away right so that I just was like all
right and then I finally got a customer
service person on the phone that was
cool that in English told me how to
solve the problem myself like that's how
bad customer service has gotten like
where they're not going to do it for you
but they're just like now you need to go
to our website and not your app
right okay okay my point is we always
have a choice
thank you so much for your help yeah
nobody cares well we care yeah for sure
yep and that's I think that's what makes
a difference that is what makes the
different people like Inc ADCO care yep
good smart with us yeah like I need to
get more stickers printed up I gotta
call the guys over in Catco because it's
like get somebody on the phone
they'll resolve the problem they'll
trying to make it work and there's
something I support small businesses
whenever I can
there are some good bigger biz I'm
trying to think of a bigger business
that I've enjoyed that I've had a good
experience for Costco's really good to
the room they are I've heard that too
like they give them like 15 bucks an
hour yeah living wage great benefits a
lot of upward mobility they reward hard
work actually I have sort of a good one
kind of a negative one
I took an uber home the other night and
it was like 2:30 in the morning I just
done a podcast I was tired of the cars
is that when you did after school
special drugs yes so I just want to be
safe it's 2:00 in the morning I'm just
gonna take an uber home I get in the car
and the guys watching TV while he's
driving
oh and I wasn't shy like for a second I
was just listening to like a podcast
sort of thing mm-hmm because I was I
ended up sitting behind him yeah and I
looked around and he had a phone mounted
on the on the dashboard watching of
something on Netflix yeah and I was just
- I didn't I should have said something
I didn't but I will give it up to Ober I
emailed them as soon as I got home and
within five minutes they had refunded it
to me and and sent an apology letter so
they're not always the best but that I I
appreciate it then half-10 you have to
speak up you have to like that's one of
the things like I'm the sweetest guy
ever yeah but I have a real problem
where I feel like if I feel like I'm
being taken advantage of where I'm like
Oh wrong you're wrong here or you're not
again then I get really I get a little
aggressive
which is hard especially because III
think we're similar we're try to be nice
to everybody and sure you can
everybody's fighting a hard fight but
there's two types of people in the world
there's people in the world with that
when you treat them great they're gonna
go oh my god you're you know what you're
an awesome person I'm gonna treat you
even better than you're treating me or
very at the very least I appreciate your
kindness right like we can use a
metaphor for a restaurant like if you're
the nicest customer in there look I
understand you have but in some
waitresses are like oh my god you're a
sweetheart
whatever and they work harder for you
they get it and they're like you know
what I'm just gonna refill that commit
and they start then there's other people
are like oh this this idiot doesn't have
a spine they mistake it for weakness and
then they don't come over to your table
and and then it's like oh that's where
you're wrong so now I'm trying to build
my life surrounding myself with the
people that appreciate me and appreciate
kindness and it's the same with my fans
it's the same thing with comedy
like if you're a cool cook like if you
come to the comedy store and you just
want to do coke and talk about what my
clubs you get into you're a douche bag I
don't want you coming back to my shows
so I'm glad you don't get what I'm
trying to do I'm like there's comedians
for you just go to you know if somebody
that's just gonna make fun of everything
and tell you what's wrong with the world
cool but if you're somebody that's like
hey man I need to be reminded that
there's good things in the world thank
you for making me laugh I'll do it like
I've handed out more stickers this
weekend that gave away a couple of free
t-shirts because there were so many
awesome people yeah juxtaposed to the
really stinky selfish people so I just
focus on the awesome well that's a great
way to live life it's hard it's hard
sometimes I'm I know I'm trying to do it
I know a lot of people listening or
trying to do it and I think the choice
remind yourself I guess I don't know I I
firmly believe we're having this talk
for a reason so because somebody out
there probably needs to hear it just be
reminded that you always have a choice I
think there's some of yours hard for
people it's getting towards the end of
the year you see bills are starting to
come up and then yeah I'm started
thinking about vacations like Paul and I
wanted to want to go away for a few days
in December and I can't afford like a
plane ticket right now yeah that we were
looking at doing a couple things and
then between plane tickets and the
hotels
yeah every
three three days I can't afford to spend
to spend $1,000
I don't blame it I just I don't have it
and I got a little bit down but then now
we're looking at things within driving
distance and there's even cooler things
for less money awesome that it's just
yeah there's so many cool things like
you could go up to I think we might go
to Big Bear and rent a cabin go to Big
Bear go to Malibu for the day yeah just
go to the National Angeles National
Forest there's all kinds of cool stuff
with dude there's a mission ten minutes
from my house where Bob Hope's laid the
rest the San Fernando mission it was
beautiful peaceful park setting and I'm
like this is ten minutes from my house
really so cool it is nice going I walked
around North Hollywood Park a couple
times yesterday yeah I wanted to take a
day off time you did Fryman or Runyon
I've never done those oh I'm gonna hike
with autistic thunder on Friday if you
want to come I'm gone Friday would you
do it every Friday well I think you know
what maybe I will maybe that'll start
being the thing that can be really fun
and I'm in Runyon Fryman cuz it's less
crowded
could start having a buddy I'm totally
down guys we just came across something
awesome we're gonna start doing a buddy
meetup hike and then maybe we could
bring peanut butter and jellies or
something and have every Susan the bass
yes I will bring orange slices in water
but we're not gonna do the first one
until Lee can do it and we'll give you a
two weeks heads-up yeah so this will
come out Sunday oh yeah so next Friday
it should be okay you want to just do
that I'm general tweeted out yeah if
even it's just me you and Joshua it'll
be awesome oh yeah I'm sure some people
will come it'll be great say I'm already
in a good mood there's nothing better
than I'm not even a big fruit person but
Cole Lawrence are you and just hanging
out with your friends getting some fresh
air it'll be awesome all right Lee I
love you thank you for hanging out with
me a good times all you guys listening
thank you so much for hanging out call
your mom this week tell her that you
appreciate her that was the most
influential person Ali's life and
Christina is gonna be the best mom ever
and it's just a special thing to be so
uh
got for moms thank God for you guys
listening and friends take care of kapa
lesson have a great week